10 ways to have better conversations
this is gonna be
a reaction video on one of the most
popular ted talks that exists it's got
over 30 million views just between
youtube and ted
and i'm going to have celeste speak for
herself on her 10 tips
and then i'm going to offer my two cents
as soon as you hear her
share her tip offer my two cents
contribution on
the concept she's talking about
counting down here we go no time wasted
number 10
celeste would say don't try to multitask
and i don't mean just set down your cell
phone or your tablet or your car keys or
whatever is in your hand
i mean be present be in that
moment don't be thinking about your
argument you have with your boss don't
be thinking about
what you're going to have for dinner if
you want to get out of the conversation
get out of the conversation
but don't be half in it and half out of
it my take on this
is asking the question asking yourself
the question maybe asking the group the
question or the person you're talking
with
are you present it's one of the most
powerful questions that was asked to me
in my own life so are you present number
nine
don't pontificate she shares absolutely
one of my favorite quotes from
bill nye and we'll just hear her say it
in her voice
if you wanted to state your opinion
without
any opportunity for response or argument
or pushback or
growth write a blog
now there's a really good reason why i
don't allow pundits on my show
because they're really boring if they're
a conservative they're going to hate
obama and food stamps and abortion
if they're a liberal they're going to
hate big banks and oil corporations and
dick cheney
totally predictable and you don't want
to be like that
you need to enter every conversation
assuming that you have something to
learn
the famed therapist ebb scott peck said
that true listening requires a setting
aside
of oneself and sometimes that means
setting aside
your personal opinion he said that
sensing this acceptance the speaker will
become
less and less vulnerable and more and
more likely to open up the inner
recesses of his or her mind
to the listener again assume that you
have
something to learn bill nye everyone you
will ever meet knows something that you
don't
i put it this way everybody is an expert
in something when you're up here
everybody's down there and it's not very
connecting for conversation
in other words as your awesomeness goes
up
your relatedness goes down number eight
stay out of the weeds frankly people
don't
care about the years the names
the dates all those details that you're
struggling to come up
with in your mind they don't care what
they care about is you
they care about what you're like what
you have in common
so forget the details leave them out
last invite you use open-ended
questions in this case take a cue from
journalists start your questions with
who what where when why or how
if you put in a complicated question
you're going to get a simple answer out
if i ask you were you terrified you're
gonna respond
to the most powerful word in that
sentence which is terrified and the
answer is
yes i was or no i wasn't were you angry
yes i was very angry
let them describe it they're the ones
that know
try asking them things like what was
that like
how did that feel because then they
might have to stop for a moment
and think about it and you're gonna get
a much more interesting response
my take on this a little more specific i
would invite you to use questions that
only begin with how or what and not
why why questions typically invite
people to defend and they have some
judgment embedded in them so just ask
questions that begin with how
or what celeste says go with the flow
that means thoughts will come into your
mind and you need to
let them go out of your mind we've heard
interviews
often in which a guest is talking for
several minutes and then the host comes
back in and asked a question which seems
like it comes out of nowhere
or it's already been answered that means
the host probably stopped listening two
minutes ago because
he thought of this really clever
question
and he was just bound and determined to
say that and we do the exact same thing
we're sitting there having a
conversation with someone and then we
remember that
time that we met hugh jackman in a
coffee shop
and we stopped listening stories and
ideas are going to come to you
you need to let them come and let them
go
my take with go with the flow is
actually continue to be
curious to that person curiosity
when it's natural and it's genuine is
kind of like the natural
flowingness of a river it might wind and
take you to some unexpected places
but it's still going to be flowing and
that is really great for conversation
and so be
curious also as you're listening number
five
if you don't know say you don't know now
people on the radio especially on npr
are much more aware that they're going
on the record and so they're more
careful
about what they claim to be an expert in
and what they claim to know for sure
do that err on the side of caution talk
should not be cheap number four don't
equate your experience
with theirs if they're talking about
having lost a family member
don't start talking about the time that
you lost a family member if you're
talking about the trouble that they're
having at work
don't tell them about how much you hate
your job it's not the same
it is never the same all experiences are
individual
and more importantly it is not about you
you don't need to take that moment to
prove how amazing you are
or how much you've suffered somebody
asked stephen hawking once what his iq
was and he says i have no idea people
who brag about their iqs are losers
conversations are not a promotional
opportunity
just don't say i know how you feel you
don't you're not them you didn't have
the exact same experience and they will
be sure to point out they will be quick
to point out
that they didn't have the exact same
experience as you
the tool for that is maybe describe the
world as you think they see it
and let them correct you and add in
number three
try not to repeat yourself it's
condescending and it's really boring
and we tend to do it a lot especially in
work conversations
or in conversations with our kids we
have a point to make so we just keep
rephrasing it over and over
don't do that i'm not gonna repeat what
celestia said
number two listen more this is not the
last one but it is the most
important one listen i cannot tell you
how many
really important people have said that
listening is perhaps the most
the number one most important skill that
you could develop buddha said and i'm
paraphrasing
if your mouth is open you're not
learning and calvin coolidge said
no man ever listened his way out of a
job
why do we not listen to each other
number one
we'd rather talk when i'm talking i'm in
control i don't have to hear anything
i'm not interested in
i'm the center of attention i can
bolster my own identity
but there's another reason we get
distracted the average person talks at
about 225 words per minute
but we can listen at up to 500 words per
minute
so our minds are filling in those other
275 words
and look i know it takes effort and
energy
to actually pay attention to someone but
if you can't do that you're not in a
conversation
you're just two people shouting out
barely related sentences in the same
place
you have to you have to listen to one
another stephen covey said it very
beautifully he said
most of us don't listen with the intent
to understand
we listen with the intent to reply the
question i would give you that a teacher
of mine gave to me to help you listen
more
is one of my favorite questions two
words what else
listen to what somebody else said and
then just say what else
what else you could rephrase that but
just what else what else
and number one be brief
[Laughter]
[Music]
all of this boils down to the same basic
concept and it is this one
be interested in other people you know i
grew up with a very famous grandfather
and there was kind of a ritual
in my home people would come over to
talk to my grandparents
and after they would leave my mother
would come over to us and she'd say
do you know who that was she was the
runner up to miss america
he was the mayor of sacramento she won a
pulitzer prize he's a russian ballet
dancer
and i started i kind of grew up assuming
everyone has some hidden amazing thing
about them
and i honestly i think it's what makes
me a better host
i keep my mouth shut as often as i
possibly can i keep my mind open
and i'm always prepared to be amazed and
i'm never disappointed
you do the same thing go out
talk to people listen to people and most
importantly
be prepared to be amazed how can i add
to that i'll keep it brief
if you love this video i chop up short
clips of these videos and post them all
over social media so if you just want
like the 60 second 120 second bit
go ahead and search me on any social
media platform would love to meet and be
in conversation with you there i'm chad
littlefield
have an awesome day